My first reaction watching
Surviving Paradise
is how affecting it was.
It's very personal.
It's small.
It's about being
able to empathise
with the characters
in the documentary,
which is super close
to what I do every day
at work anyway.
It's all about figuring out
what we can learn about
the world through empathy,
how we can empathise
with what these animals
are going through,
on a kind of very personal
level, and from that,
learning what our place
in that drama is.
It's gotta be
the lone mother lioness
when she's hunting,
for her kids,
and fighting off
the stronger male lions,
all by herself,
just to kinda keep this
little family unit together.
I think that's the kind of
thing that I'm talking about
that I think people will
relate to quite personally
on a strange level,
because everyone
knows what it's like
to be a parent fighting
for your family.
And you know,
people have watched
their parents
do that for them.
And that's kind of something
that I think can
connect everyone.
It's very universal.
I think it was the elephants
being gardeners.
I've never actually kind
of thought of elephants
as being
particularly helpful.
They tend to kind of
take down trees and crops.
But this idea that they are
gardening the environment,
that they kinda
take down trees
that create pathways
and waterways
for the water to flow along
in the wet season
in the floodplains,
how they work
with the hippos,
about how all
of that interlinks
with how they spread seeds
from various fruits.
I think finding how
everything has its purpose
and its place in maintaining
the environment
was definitely the coolest
piece that I learnt.
Our central focus
was in creating
a dramatic narrative
that an audience
can hold onto
and relate to
and empathise with.
And so it was all about just
finding the through lines
of what are these animals
going through
on a personal level.
How does that link
into the wider picture?
And how can I help
communicate that
with an audience in a very
visceral and entertaining
and funny and tragic way
so that you go on
a whole journey with us?
It's tricky
'cause I'm a city kid,
I live in London,
but I think the joy is that
London's a very green city.
And so, I try to get
to the parks whenever I can.
I love watching
the seasons change,
the leaves
coming off the trees.
I think there's those
unexpected bits of wildlife,
even in urban environments.
London has a population
of parakeets,
which is the most
unexpected piece of wildlife
you'd think of
in this part of the world.
I think they might have
escaped a zoo or a film set.
The main thing
I hope audiences
take away and learn
is how interconnected
everything is.
How the actions
of one animal
affects the other animals,
how that affects
the environment,
how the environment then
feeds back
into those animals,
how what we do affects
the changing environment.
There's the whole section
with the elephants
and how they have
a generational memory
that they pass on,
of the routes
that they go to find water,
of the routes that they take
to avoid fires,
of techniques that
they take to avoid fires,
and how they pass that down.
And how all of that changes,
depending on how
we change their environment.
And so, 80-year-old
knowledge
that's five generations old
in elephants
that suddenly
comes under threat because
those pathways to waters
don't exist anymore
because of what we've done.
And it's how nothing lives
in isolation anymore.
Everything that we do
outside of the delta
affects things in the delta.
Everything that happens
in the delta
affects everything else
in the delta.
So, it's just
that everything's connected
and there's nowhere
to hide from that, really.